the thing about fighting dude these days
there's a lot of [__] [__]
especially Americans and Americans are
the biggest [__] [__] how so like I
mean how many current American Champs
are there correct like you know you look
at this badass [__] Brazilian just
knock me out like bro it's like
Americans are soft as [__] dude too much
[__] Starbucks life is [__] too
good for you [__] too
comfortable I'm almost like I'm almost
I'm almost hoping Russia [__] nukes
us just so our [__] nuts get a little
bigger dude you guys are too soft we're
too soft yeah [__] beta males they're
[__] man buns and [__] there's
probably a couple man buns behind me let
me see yeah there's less things one man
bun no well I mean but they all could
have [__] man buns we could have some
you so you think you're like the last
yeah and I'm the last white trap I'm the
90s bro Patrick [__] Swayze ride
motorcycles dude [__] hot women like you
[__] now you guys sell your soul for
[__] [__] you bunch of [__] beta
males you [__] dirty leftists like no
I'm saying like